remember your very uh striking role in
uh the movie wanderlust you were you
were playing a nudist so you were in
fact naked
i was
mostly naked it looked like you were
really all the way naked i as i recall
and i've watched the scene hundreds of
times hope you had it on luke well thank
you conan i'm flattered i had a
prosthetic penis
oh hi
yes the the news is out i feel better
now
uh yes and before we started shooting i
thought it might be a good idea to maybe
meet the special effects guy before you
know
you know day one starts and he's up in
my business and whatnot so so this is a
guy who's putting and i hate to be
graphic but i just need to understand as
a host go ahead he's putting a fake
penis over your real penis correct
correct
that's right he what happened was i said
i called him up and i said let's let's
meet somewhere and we shot in george
somewhere romantic
well here's what happened i ended up
picking the applebee's in gainesville
georgia
because i was shooting in northern
georgia and he was on atlanta i said
let's meet halfway so we go we go to the
applebee's and we're having lunch we're
doing some small talk and this and that
and finally
you know i said let's let's get down to
it how does this work he's like well
yeah you take this prosthetic thing and
we glue it over the real thing there's
this piece of nylon that's going to go
between your butt we're going to glue it
there and i'm like oh well that sounds
awful
and he says well it is and i said uh all
right well let's let's see it
he's let's see it and he said well we
have to go to the car
i have to go to the car i wish it was a
van
[Laughter]
and i'm sitting shotgun and and he takes
out a shoe box
and takes the lid off and there there's
the piece and i and i take it out and he
also needed the check i'm playing a
nudist whether or not he needed to add
more chest to my very hairy chest so now
i'm lifting my shirt and i have the the
penis there the fake penis there and
where are you right now i'm in a parking
lot in gainesville georgia applebee's
in a pony a great pontiac vibe
the vibe was not good
that's a very hard thing to explain to
anybody who walks by yeah there's no
explaining it no
no oh you don't understand
it's not what it looks like no it looks
like you have a fake penis and you're
lifting your shirt to naked